aaron rodgers and shailene whitley have
called it quits after less than two
years together and a year after she
confirmed their engagement
yes we are engaged we are engaged a
source tells e.t that the nfl mvp and
actress quote tried to make their
relationship work
but with busy careers in different
industries it was hard to see one
another yeah there's no wedding planning
happening it's there's no rush the
source adds that they quote have no
animosity toward one another and plan to
remain as friends but with no clear
explanation for the split the online
rumor mill is working overtime and some
fans speculate politics got in the way
are you vaccinated and what's your
stance on vaccinations yeah i've been
immunized aaron's controversial stance
on vaccines has been a reoccurring
headline for a while now back in august
he claimed he was quote immunized
against covet 19 but he didn't actually
get one of the fda approved vaccines for
the virus instead aaron claimed to
undergo a quote alternative treatment
prior to the start of training camp and
he apparently petitioned the nfl to
consider that mystery treatment as equal
to getting vaxxed like everyone else on
his team
this all came to light when aaron tested
positive for covet 19 in november
forcing him to miss games fans were in a
uproar but at the time aaron claimed he
had to skip the shot because he's quote
allergic to what's in the vaccine
i believe strongly in bodily autonomy
and the ability to make choices for your
body not to have to acquiesce to some
woke culture
or crazed you know
group of individuals who say you have to
do something health is not a one size
fits all
for everybody and shailene came to her
then fiance's defense after one outlet
reported that aaron had broken his covet
19 quarantine to get coffee in los
angeles the 30 year old took to
instagram to slam the report writing in
part quote literally y'all need to calm
down news outlets still grasping at
straws to disparage aaron finding random
men on the streets of la and saying it's
him the big little lies actress went on
to point out that the man in the photo
looked nothing like aaron quote i know
aaron's body very well
adding this of the feet quote no offense
to this rando dude errands are a lot
bigger nobody knows the full story
last february shailene revealed to jimmy
fallon that she and the nfl pro were
engaged
not long after they started dating
during the pandemic he's first off just
a wonderful incredible human being but i
never thought i'd be engaged with
somebody who threw balls for a living
like i never thought as a little girl i
was like yeah when i grew up i'm gonna
marry someone who
who throws balls yeah
um but he's really just so good at it
shortly after news broke up their
engagement ichi spoke to shailene's pal
megan park the two co-starred for years
on the secret life of the american
teenager i'm going to go get the photos
from the shower from my car okay thanks
amy and the actress opened up about her
thoughts on her friend taking her
relationship with aaron to the next
level i like aaron a lot i have not met
him in real life yet because of covid
but i met him over face time and he's a
great guy and i couldn't be more
thrilled for them
[Music]